penny morden in a few weeks time you
could become the prime minister of this
country you have had
a storming week
you are now second in the race to
replace boris johnson amongst mps you've
gone from an outside runner really to
being one of the favorites but you're
also quite unknown and your cabinet
experience isn't
as uh fulsome as rishi sanakul is trust
do you acknowledge that you're a risky
bet
no i mean i don't have a profile because
in the last few years i've been
beavering away in the department of
trade and in the cabinet office getting
us through a pandemic and securing trade
deals and i've just been getting on with
my job
but i've thought long and hard about
what this country needs how do we
maximize the opportunities of leaving
the eu which is something i voted for
and i'm passionate about and really
listening to people of this country
about how they want to modernize their
politics how they want to get government
to be more responsive to their needs and
so i feel really compelled to do this it
would be a huge honor to be prime
minister
no no not even a little bit
just what an opportunity you know we we
have come through some really difficult
times politically
and through the through the pandemic and
we have all this opportunity ahead of us
so i would be so proud to do that job
and uh it's the greatest country in the
world and just on a practical note uh it
seems to me that the race to get to the
final two for you is going to get a lot
harder in the coming days that's because
when you look at who else is in the race
liz trust has picked up the support of
swella bravo man a chunk of her 27 votes
go into his trust kami badanok backers
unlikely to break for you with some of
the brexiteers in the party kind of
having an anyone but penny mordant
approach are you worried now that trust
is going to overtake you
we are running a confident campaign and
it's got values and teamwork at its
heart and if you look at where we're
attracting support from it's from across
the party
at the end of this contest we have to
unite the party hold it together and
critically win a general election and my
campaign isn't just about winning this
contest it's about winning that election
jeremy hunt didn't back you which i was
surprised at given that in 2019 you
supported him and then lost your seat in
the cabinet as boris johnson
kind of got his revenge on you for that
were you disappointed by that
people have to
you know they're good colleagues they
have to do what they think is right but
i'm attracting support from scotland
from red wool from blue wall and that's
i think in part because of how i'm
polling in the country but anne-marie
trevelyan who uh is your boss
uh and jeremy hunt who you bat they're
not backing you does that say something
about your competence maybe
well they're they're backing other
candidates and they're perfectly
entitled to do that and they'll have
their their own reasons for doing that
but you know these are these are other
teams people obviously are trying to
stop me getting into the final because
they don't want to run against me who's
trying to stop you well other other
candidates you know this is a this is
the greatest prize it is the greatest
country in the world and it's being
prime minister of that country so
understandably people having seen my
polling and having how seeing how i
would fare against them in the in the
final round of this contest it's
understandable they're trying
rishi sonnet does not want to have to go
against you with party members does he
because you're more popular well i and
in the polling that's been done i beat
all other candidates yeah so so
basically there's a race on to stop
penny more don't get into the final two
but more critically the polling shows
that i also beat kierstarma in places
like london for example okay
there's an allegation made by lord frost
that you're
uh there's a lack of cabinet experience
he says that you were not fully
accountable always visible you did not
master the necessary detail that's what
he said about you
again he's in another camp
people aren't going to try and stop me
and it's right that's it's right anyone
going for this job it needs to be tested
in scrutiny i know but it must sting
doesn't it these attacks on you do you
not care i i care about my colleagues i
have great colleagues and we have to at
the end of this contest
come together as a party you'll see from
my campaign that i'm not engaging in any
of that
and i think that's really important
we're going to campaign as we would
govern as a party but there is a risk
isn't there penny morgan that if
different cabinet ministers and senior
members of the party keep telling
colleagues that there are doubts about
your competence and ability that that
could affect how you go i mean this is
what simon clark chief secretary to the
treasury said to skype it's telling i
think where con current members of the
government are placed in support that's
reflected a number of very senior
ministers decisions about who to support
they're not backing mismordent well i
think the evidence is to the contrary
i'm in second place and i think beth one
of the reasons why that is having not
had the platforms that some others have
in this contest is that i am running a
positive campaign and i'm talking in
this campaign about the issues that the
public are worried about people are
really worried already and looking ahead
to autumn about the cost of okay let's
just i'm going to get on to one thing to
finish off this section then about the
race what's your message to other
candidates and other campaigns is it to
lay off and run a cleaner campaign i
think it's legitimate for you who's
getting absolutely smashed up at the
moment to call for that i would talk
about the merits of my approach which is
to not just win this contest but to win
a general election and that's why i'm
not engaging in any of your message
campaigns it's it's you might like to
think about doing the same because the
worst thing would be is if we come out
of this contest not in good shape i want
us to come out in brilliant shape i want
us to have formed a team throughout this
process and go forward start really
delivering on the issues this country
cares about and absolutely smash labor
the liberal democrats and our other
opponents at the general election if we
don't win
that election
then all of the good work we have done
since we have left the eu will be for
nothing okay well look let's talk about
some of the policies that you stand for
let's start with the economy
you say you will allow income tax
thresholds to rise with inflation this
is estimated to cost around 80 billion
18 billion pounds between now and 2026.
what were you uh cut in terms of
spending to pay for that well these are
these are forecasts so we will have to
adjust that
um but in this contest apart from that
policy and uh and other really targeted
support measures to help on cost of
living that that cut on on fuel at the
pump i have not done what other
candidates have done which is to make
rash spending commitments talk about
corporation tax levels and so forth the
there's a really important reason why
that is the case we we have an autumn
budget coming up these issues should be
looked at
with a team in the round
when we have a full appreciation of the
of the fiscal year so you so you're more
aligned with rishi sunak on that really
which is like let's just not make wild
tax promises uh i'm i'm in agreement
with him that
this contest should not be the place for
making those decisions but where i
differ from rishi
is that i am focused on growth and my
principles about future tax decisions
unlike the decisions he's taken on
corporation tax for example are that
this country must compete is rishi sonak
just is he too rich to become prime
minister is his huge family wealth
and what his wife's non-dom state status
now train is that that could be a real
problem couldn't it in a time of a cost
of living crisis
look i have huge respect for all of my
running mates i think that we shouldn't
be doing each other down or
uh commenting on each other in in that
way um i think they all have a lot of
great qualities i think they are would
be fantastic as a as a team i guess that
sorry but i i think that you it's really
important for the kind of shift we're
going to have
that we do have empathy
and understand what it is like now
other people can can do that but
sometimes if you've had particular
experiences in life you can pick up on
things that others miss
i was just gonna i was asking really
because also given that
what's happened with boris johnson and
how the public felt about some of issues
around character and conduct you really
can't have another person that takes
office that then has issues around
character or conduct or tax status can
you you can't because you can't have
another scandalous number 10.
i think we all know in this race that
there needs to be a real reset and that
these issues matter greatly to the
public
they want to see
it's not just about some of the issues
we've seen recently it's about
uh our whole approach to this country
and our care of other people and i think
what you're saying is you feel that
you're more in touch than maybe someone
like rishi sanak i think that's what
you're saying that's fair isn't it i'm
not going to make any comments about
other candidates
what i think i bring my strengths are
that i've i've experienced quite a lot
of uh difficulties in my life
and i think that's important and it
helps you understand how to better
deliver services to people why it's
really important that you don't have a
lot of bureaucracy because people
dealing with stressful situations are
exhausted sometimes and sometimes
dealing with government services is is
really stressful pennywood actually just
on the issue about kind of people's
lives and the reality of people eyes
versus what's going on in westminster
with this tory leadership contest
that your your party is spending this
campaign taking pot shots at each other
over tax cuts over trans issues when in
the real world the nhs is in an
unprecedented crisis
and in your launch this week i think you
had an opportunity to talk about some of
that but actually what you announced was
was a task force i
mean that's a bit
i'm underwhelming i'm not talking about
those other issues all the other
candidates in this contest
my launch and everything that we have
done has been focused on growth and
competition to get our economy fired up
and build a modern economy fit for the
modern world but also on those very real
issues that are a problem for people
cost of living the fact that people are
struggling to access certain health care
services or there it takes ages to get a
blood test result and although it's not
the big long list of detailed things we
need to do in order to resolve some of
those issues in the health service
we have to recognize that unless we
change the way whitehall is approaching
these issues we're not going to be so
this administration this administration
not good enough up to now basically
people want us to deliver if we can't
deliver on these basic things uh then we
are not this administration hasn't been
delivering has it i think it's important
that we don't
trash our record right because actually
we have done an
awful lot of good things a huge amount
of work has gone on in terms of
rebuilding and reshaping our regulation
and all of those things since we left
the eu there's been some great work done
on in education and all of those things
but what is causing us real
difficulty now as a nation is we've
obviously just been through a pandemic
there is a massive catch-up job to do on
health and education and we really do
need to have much more focus in
whitehall on those sorts of issues
that's true but some people be watching
us thinking yes and we need someone
that's
in the cabinet at the moment that's been
that that we can trust to kind of run
the government to do that rather than
you but i mean that's your
that's your case to make
well i would say that i've i've a lot of
experience i've worked in a lot of
governments i've managed the largest
dell budgets in
any government department i've had
international facing roles i've had
domestic facing roles i've worked on
toughness do you think it's a bit unfair
when people say you're inexperienced i
have a i have a lot of experience and
a broad experience as well but my
campaign is not
just about a leader at the top that
entire model of leadership is failing
everywhere and we need to build teams we
need to have smart people okay around
that penny morgan you were the former
defense secretary just quickly
percentage of gdp should be on defense
spending what what is it liz trust and
tom tokenheart saying three percent what
do you say so in this contest i've
committed to at least meeting our
manager that's 2.5 2.5 and i've also
said that i would expect that to have to
tick up slightly because three percent
no i'm not making commitments to three
percent i'll tell you why but um because
of increased costs it may have to rise
slightly but again this contest is not
the place to make those decisions and
actually
plucking figures out of the air is is
not a sensible thing to do i i have had
a reservist career um i am uh absolutely
committed to our armed forces and i know
that it is the first duty of any prime
minister uh to make sure this nation is
defended but what we spend needs to be
uh uh tailored to our needs and our
future
that's fair enough that's a fair enough
answer let's go on to social issues and
policy you describe yourself to one
nation conservative and you're clearly
socially liberal your twin brother james
uh who is gay and you've you've put
pictures out of you in on lovely
pictures of you on the pride marches
together
he's condemned the conservatives being
complicit in anti-lgbt
bigotry is that hard for you when he
says that
and do you disagree with him
he i i do disagree with him obviously
but uh we're able to do that and i think
it's really important people
are able to express their own views uh
have that debate i think it's really
important that the conservatives
are there for everyone in this country
[Music]
i've
in previous roles i've held in the
equalities office
very aware of some of the challenges
particular sections of our community
feel and its government's job to be
addressing
those needs but i do think we've got a
good record of things that we have done
particularly on things like health care
and so forth we put together the first
ever lgbt action plan in this country
and if i were prime minister i would
want to take those positive things
forward what do you mean by a danger of
excluding some people with this war and
woke i mean there's these culture issues
culture war issues seem to be stoked up
by members of the conservative party i
think that is a fair thing to say isn't
it look
i want to talk about it it's an issue
though
but i think i think you're right i want
to talk about cost of living yeah access
to health care those sorts of issues not
toilets in this camp yeah but
kami badanok's campaign
took away gender-neutral toilets at the
launch and put men and women on there is
that not the sort of thing your
brother's talking about when he
criticizes the tories stance on
so-called woke issues look i'm a i'm a
small state conservative
i think
government shouldn't be telling
pubs and clubs what their toilet policy
is i think we should be concentrating on
the big issues that are worrying and
terrifying in some cases the public the
huge cost of living issues that we have
access to health care just the services
that they want to see run
really efficiently from their state i
get that but what did you think about
the bad knocks did it irritate you did
you just think what why are you doing
that or did you i mean no look
kemi kemi is running a great campaign
and it's kemi and uh rishi's running his
campaign that's swishy
the excitement about this contest is you
have you have different candidates with
different perspectives and priorities
my priorities for the economy a growth
and competition and my priorities for
the country are to focus on the issues
that they're concerned let's just clear
this up though let's just clear up here
and now because these sorts of issues
around trans issues and you
do you think women have the right to
exclude trans women from single sex
spaces such as changing rooms women's
prisons even if that means transsexual
people are refused entry
so i think the policy we have in england
at the moment is the right one which is
that you you can have a plurality of
provision so for things like women's
refuges for example there are some that
would exclude a trans person there are
some that wouldn't
if you have a policy as the line they're
going down in scotland i think you get
into difficulty which is that you don't
have the plurality in service and again
this is why it makes
no sense for government to be
prescribing bathroom policies too but do
you think women have the right to
exclude trans women from some spaces
that's all i want to do i do you do okay
um
just on this issue if you
let me just ask you a second question on
this
um
kierstama believes trans women are women
again let's clear up what do you think
so
i'm biologically a woman yes uh
if i had a mastectomy or a part of my
body i would still be a woman because i
am a woman in every cell of my body um
but some people
who are born male will go through a
process to transition into another
gender and they are issued a legal
document
in their new gender they are not
biological women
like me
but the law recognizes them in their new
gender and that that's very simple and
straightforward and
westminster is tying itself in knots
over it
and i think women can be women legally
can be women legally but not
biologically and we are not equivalent
in that respect and i mean people should
look at my my record on this uh i was
raising for example the issue of of
uh trans people competing against uh
women in sport many you're opposed to
that um yes and i know what this is like
i i have had a career in the royal navy
i compete against men
and it's very annoying because no matter
how hard i trained i was usually uh last
or one of the last so i do understand
this and i understand because i've
spoken to her about it sharon davis why
she was so aggrieved when she was
competing and she was running against
people who had had testosterone in their
systems why that is so unfair but
it's not it's not anti-trans to be
gripping these sorts of issues and i
think we do need to grip them do you
feel a bit aggrieved that people are
turning this into a stick to beat you
with i mean swella bravmen talking about
you wanting pregnant person in
legislation not pregnant woman do you
feel that this is the thing that could
torpedo your
campaign this this issue i would say
look at how we're doing in the polls in
the country
in london in scotland with young people
with women with red wall with blue wall
it's not having an impact on my campaign
and it's not having an impact on my
parliamentary campaign and i think the
reason for that beth is that people
recognize it for what it is i understand
why people are trying to stop me getting
into the final two but i am going to
stay focused on the things that matter
to the public and the people we're here
to serve they do care about these issues
but they're not the things that they
want their government to be obsessing
with they want us focus on helping them
through this cost of living situation
and on getting them access to the nhs
that they pay a lot of money for and all
the other things that they want to help
support their lives penny i've run out
of time but i have to ask you this final
thing you're obviously really close to
your brother james family's really
important to you you lost your mum
when you were a teenager i think which
must have been extremely hard you're not
married and you're not a mother if you
win this race you'd be the first single
prime minister since edward heath you'll
remember the issue around theresa may in
2016 and the issue about her not being a
mother does it irritate you that
motherhood and marriage are still
relevant
when we discuss women in positions of
power
so i think they're relevant to men and
women because of the experience that
comes from it i think a lot of uh
certainly a lot of the reason why i was
so interested in politics at a young age
was because of the experiences that i
had trying to help my family and and
keep the household going in quite
strained times so i think those
experiences are important um but yes the
the question not that you would ask at
best
why aren't you married is never asked to
men
and you'd never answer it presumably
because it's no one's business apart
from yours i'd probably answer it but
you could never share it on television
oh my goodness can we do that off camera
okay one other thing and then i'm going
to let you go because you've got so much
to do sky news is holding a debate
between the remaining candidates next
tuesday would you be part of that
leadership debate yes i will and i'll
look forward to it thank you very much
penny morden thank you so much for your
time thanks thank you
and our political editor beth rugby
joins you now such an interesting
interview there beth
what were the key things that stood out
for you
well there are a number of things that
stood out for me the fast is that penny
mordant is having to introduce herself
if you like to the british public the
parliamentary party
might know her well but now that she is
facing the prospect or with the prospect
of getting into that final two i think
she's going to increase uh her media
appearances and attempt to try and
tell the public what she's about but in
terms of the campaign i think the first
thing that struck me in that interview
was her determination to try and run a
clean campaign there were no attack
lines uh really overt ones at least
on some of her competitors but she was
clear too
that their attacks on her were all
driven by a fear
of her getting into the final two and
she kept saying as she rightly should in
a way given what the polling has showed
is that if penny mordant does make it to
the final round of the final two
candidates and it's really between her
rishi sonic and liz truss
then she has a real chance of winning uh
this contest because she's popular with
party members so that's the first thing
on the politics and i think there was a
dig there at rishi sanak it wasn't avert
it was implicit
when i asked her about whether or not
some of his should talk about the cost
of living i said is he too rich
to be prime minister is in touch with
people and she made a comment about
people different candidates having maybe
more uh in common or more relatable to
other people i thought that was a slight
dig at rishi sunup but she was very
careful to try not to
have naked attacks on other candidates
even though she is getting absolutely
pilloried uh from the other teams when i
asked her about all of those criticisms
she was consistently clear it's because
they are trying to stop me now on policy
i thought she was interested in that
unlike other candidates she will not go
into detail
about what her government would do in
terms of tax and spend she didn't really
engage on the question of the nhs which
i think if she gets through to the
further rounds of this campaign she
clearly is going to have to because
that's what really matters to people at
the moment and then on defense spending
as well she wouldn't commit to a three
percent target saying now is not the
time uh to set these policies even
though uh other candidates such as tom
tugginhart and liz truss are
and then the matter of trans issues and
is a woman a woman and is a trans woman
a woman now this has been a clear line
of attack on penny mordent by some of
the other
competitors who argue
that she is perhaps in a different
position when it comes to trans issues
than others in the parliamentary party
or the country so i tried to kind of
really take her to task on that and
clear some of that up
and she was clear wasn't she on the
issue of
single sex spaces there's been some
confusion about whether she was in favor
of that or not well she said today in
that interview yes i am in favor of
single sex spaces and then on the issue
of a trans woman and can a trans woman
be a woman penny maldon was clear there
too she said legally a trans woman can
be a woman but biologically they are not
and she also made it clear
that she didn't think that transsexual
women should compete against biological
women
in sports so i think she's trying there
to set out her stall on these matters in
order to try and get clarity and maybe
move
the debate away from some of these
issues that perhaps matter internally
to the conservative party in this race
but when it comes to the wider country
maybe these are not the key issues
on other people's minds instead she said
i don't want to be obsessing about some
issues when there are more important
issues in her view
for the country
to focus on
broadly in terms of penny mordant look
she is a relative unknown
she doesn't have tons of cabinet
experience you might not as viewers be
that familiar with her but in eight
weeks time
she could become the prime minister of
this country so this is the fast this
was an exclusive interview the first
time she's done a television interview
since kicking off the campaign she
committed to our sky news debate and i
think you're going to hear a lot of her
in the coming days as she tries to
really uh get the support of
conservative backbenchers i just say one
final thing about all of this in terms
of the race where are we after the
second round of ballots yesterday well
penny mordant is in second place behind
rishi sunak he is now on 101 votes you
need 120
that's the magic number to get through
to the final round but she is being
chased very enthusiastically by liz
truss who
won the endorsement of swella bravaman
the attorney general who dropped out or
was eliminated from the race yesterday
so as it stands penny mordent is ahead
of liz truss but as kemi badanock and
swella braveman drop out of the race
braverman's already gone kemi badanox in
fourth place these candidates are on the
right of the party and that could mean
that liz tross leapfrogs over penny
mordent in the coming days it's
completely open wide at the moment as to
which candidates end up in the final two
uh or rather i should say rishi sunak's
team are pretty sure he will get their
confident he'll get there but which
other candidate will be in that final it
could be penny morden and if she gets
there she could be our next prime
minister so it's going to get very very
heated
in the coming days as these two
key contenders liz truss and penny
mordant battle it out
to get a spot in the final two
okay beth thank you so much
and just a reminder of a special program
coming up next week sky news will
broadcast a live television debate with
those who want to be the next leader of
the conservative party and the country's
next prime minister the debate between
the candidates will take place next
tuesday at 8 00 pm the change of date
follows consultation with the candidates
and the conservative party's 1922
committee
and you can be part of the audience for
the debate to get involved and apply to
put your questions to the candidates you
can email news debates at sky dot uk